[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les rues de séoul ces électeurs
acclament le candidat démocrate li ji
young ou plutôt son sosie
ceci n'est pas une vidéo de campagne
comme les autres le vrai lit n'a pas eu
à enregistrer ce message des clones
numériques dans une campagne
présidentielle c'est une première en
corée du sud
les gens croient que c'est le vrai lit
ils disent ce n'est pa li s'est créée
par la technologie ils ont du mal à le
croire
ce député défend lui en chair et en os
le programme du candidat grand favori
des sondages en corée du sud la campagne
présidentielle a été difficile marquée
par les restrictions liées à la pandémie
de covin
lit ne peut pas visiter toutes les
régions mais grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle son sosie peut aller
partout et faire campagne en s'adaptant
à chacune des 200 26 circonscriptions
électorales
[Musique]
ces clones doivent aussi permettre aux
candidats de toucher des publics qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer facilement en
meeting comme les personnes en situation
de handicap ou les habitants de régions
rurales derrière cette révolution des
entreprises sont au service des
candidats
une tenue décontractée une autre plus
officiel différentes tonalités poser ou
enflammé peuvent s'adapter à tous les
publics toutes les situations en
écrivant de simples lignes de codes ses
ingénieurs ont modélisé le personnage de
toutes pièces troublant de réalisme
[Musique]
j'ai appris que beaucoup de gens pensent
que cette intelligence artificielle est
une vraie personne
on est conscient de ce danger donc on
s'est fixé un principe
ce sosie va dire seulement les textes
préparés par le bureau du candidat est
rien
depuis peu une loi encadre même
strictement ses sosies alors les
metaverse moins restreint et plus
interactifs se sont imposés comme de
nouveaux espaces de liberté
voici la plateforme de l'ancien candidat
and should sous dans cet univers en
ligne proche d'un jeu vidéo ces petits
personnages sont des sud-coréens venus
découvrir son programme ou échanger
entre eux
[Musique]
le lieu est convivial accessible
gratuitement et 24 heures sur 24
pendant des semaines l'homme d'affaires
qui a depuis rejoint les conservateurs
avaient même l'habitude de s'exprimer à
cette tribune tous les soirs à 20h les
semaines chez
l'homme et puis il fait son discours et
communique avec les gens là en fait ce
soir
cible privilégiée les jeunes générations
dans cette corée du sud hyperconnecté 20
% des jeunes de 20 à 30 ans ne savent
pas pour qui voter
je ne suis pas sûr que les candidats
aient bien compris le concept du
metaverse
lorsque les jeunes utilisent cette
plateforme pour s'amuser
mais la présidentielle n'est pas un jeu
les candidats veulent montrer qu'ils
sont à l'aise avec les nouvelles
technologies
trouve ça bien car il s'intéresse à
l'industrie de l'avenir
un avenir où l'on pourra voter aller à
un concert payer ses impôts sur des
plateformes virtuelles pour devenir la
première métropole metaverse la mairie
de séoul vient d'investir trois
milliards d'euros
cette nouvelle économie pourrait créer
un million d'emplois en corée du sud